declaration independence is one of the
most influential documents in all of
human history it gives a picture of the
whole order of nature and it proceeds
from that whole order down finally to
what the class is called the utmost
particular the definite thing to be done
right now how's it begin
it begins in very general terms and that
it can be applied it's not specific to
America it can be applied human events
means really anytime one people be any
people universally right in that
interesting so who are these guys and
where are these guys when they do this
they're all guys one of them was John
Adams who was a really brilliant and
great man but not as brilliant or great
as his wife who gave him happily in
writing detailed advice about everything
he did and he mostly took it really
great man so where are they apart from
the ones that are oppressing them
separated by an ocean yeah I mean
they're when they're right in this
document right they're in Philadelphia
and Philadelphia is on the sea and
Britain is a great sea power risky place
to be there were people looking for them
a writ had been issued for their arrest
and if they had been found by the army
not a police force they were not gonna
be dragged up in front of local courts
independent from the king they were
gonna be taken back to England
ripped from their families months away
right to be tried in front of strangers
which is what was going on which is one
of the complaints in the middle and
what's interesting about this is they
begin to universally but how does it end
let's look at the last sentence and for
the support somebody read this and for
the support of this declaration with a
firm reliance on the protection of
divine providence we mutually pledge to
each other Our Lives our Fortunes and
our sacred honor what else do they have
to pledge except those things
that's a pledge of everything right
we pledge all of that and who did they
pledge it to each other yeah you know
the war literature right people do
uncommonly brave things on battlefields
and many many people do it and most of
those people didn't think they could
before they did one of the themes that
emerges from the battlefield literature
is they do it for each other they don't
want to get shot they can't stand the
image of their friend getting shot can't
bear it they love right these guys are
in this room is actually the room where
the Constitution was written to later
they're in this room and they're
promising each other see that's a big
pledge and a pledge of everything and in
the name of who do they make this pledge
divine providence yeah who's that
their creator yeah as was mentioned in
the beginning of decoration penance so
God right they swear to God and to each
other